you have a video of becoming a
Kardashian type one civilization what
what's our hope for doing that were a
few orders of magnitude away from that
yeah it is surprising I think people
tend to think that we're close to this
this scale the the kardashev type one is
defined as a civilization which is using
as much energy as is essentially insulin
upon the planet from the Star
um so it's a border I think for the
Earth of something like 10 to the five
tarot so 10 to the seven terabytes is a
gigantic amount of energy and we're
using a tiny tiny tiny fraction of that
right now so
um you know if you became a college Chef
type 1 civilization which is seen not
necessarily as a goal into itself I
think people think why why are we
aspiring to become this energy hungry
civilization you know surely
um our energy needs might become you
know might improve our efficiency or
something as time goes on but ultimately
the more energy you have access to the
greater your capabilities will be I mean
if you want to lift Mount Everest into
space there is just a calculable amount
of potential energy change that that's
going to take in order to accomplish
that and the more energy you have access
to civilization then include the easier
that energy achievement is going to be
so depends on what your aspirations are
as a civilization it might not be
something you want to ever do but well
but we should make clear that lifting
heavy things isn't the only thing it's
uh it's just doing work so yeah it could
be computation it could be right it
could be more and more and more and more
sophisticated and larger and larger
larger computation which is it does seem
where we're headed with the uh very fast
increase
and um
the the scale and the quality of our
computation outside the human brain yeah
artificial computation yeah I mean
competition is a great example of I mean
already I think it's about 10 of U.S
power electricity use is going towards
the super Computing centers so there's a
there's a vast amount of uh current
engine needs which are already going
towards Computing we're surely only
increase over time
um if we start ever doing anything like
mind uploading or creating simulated
realities that that cost will surely
become almost a dominant source of our
energy requirements at that point if
civilization completely moves over to
this kind of post-humanism stage and so
it's not unreasonable that our engine
needs would continue to grow certainly
historically they always have at about
two percent per year and so if that
continues there is going to be a certain
point
um where you're running up against the
amount of energy which you can Harvest
because it's you're using every even if
you cover the entire planet and solar
panels there's no more energy to had and
so this is a you know there's a few ways
of achieving this I sort of talked about
in the video how there were several
renewable energy sources that were
excited about like geothermal wind power
waves but pretty much all of those don't
really scratch the surface or don't
really scratch the itch of getting to a
kardashev type one civilization they're
meaningful now I would never tell
anybody don't do wind power now because
it's it's clearly used for our current
stage of civilization but it's not it's
going to be a pretty negligible fraction
of our energy requirements if we got to
that stage of development and so there
has to be a breakthrough in either our
ability to harvest solar energy which
would require maybe something like a
space array of solar panels of beaming
the energy back down or some
developments and Innovations in nuclear
fusion that would allow us to
essentially reproduce the same process
of what's producing the solar photons
but here on Earth but even that comes
with some consequences if you're
generating the energy here on Earth and
you're doing work on it on a
then that work is going to produce waste
heat and that waste heat is going to
increase the ambient temperature of the
planet and so you whether even if this
isn't really a greenhouse effect that
you're increasing the temperature of the
plant this is just the amount of
computers that are churning you put your
hand to a computer you can feel the
warmth coming off them if you do that
much work of literally in you know the
entire instant energy of the planet is
doing that work uh the plant is going to
warm up significantly as a result of
that and so you know that's uh it that
clearly
indicates that this is not a sustainable
path that civilizations as they approach
color Chef type 1 are going to have to
leave planet Earth which is really the
point of that video to show that it's
a kind of Chef type 1 civilization even
though it's defined as instant energy
upon a planet that is not a species that
is going to still be living on their
Planet at least
um in isolation they will have to be
harvesting energy from afar they will
have to be you doing work on that energy
outside of their Planet because
otherwise you're going to dramatically
change the environment which you live
well yeah so the that's uh
the more energy you create the more
energy you use the more the higher the
imperative to expand out into the
universe but also not just imperative
but the uh the capabilities